we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P here's a caller
asking what is quite frankly a fair
question about Herschel Walker's runoff
against Raphael Warnock in the state of
Georgia listen to this
hey David uh this is joffer from the
Phillies suburbs yeah very excited about
Tuesday's results especially with uh
Shapiro and fetterman absolutely I just
wanted to call in to ask do you think
that Herschel walkers
staffers in preparation for the December
6th runoff are going to have to explain
to Herschel Walker that a runoff can be
something other than what he does when a
girlfriend shows up with the positive
pregnancy test
some post-election levity take care man
yeah uh so I I got the joke I get the
joke in all seriousness a few people
wrote to me and said David do you
genuinely think Herschel Walker
understands the runoff like do you think
Herschel Walker understands okay
you lost
but no one got 50 percent so now there's
a runoff
and it's only you and Raphael Warnock
and that's why we're gonna do more
campaigning is that something that
Herschel Walker understands I think
generally he understands it
even if the particulars sort of
get you know are able to are able to
evade him we're gonna get very involved
in that race that's a critical race let
me know what you think we should do as a
show about Walker Warnock and uh we will
make it happen we have such a great
bonus show for you today we're going to
talk about a strategy that Democrats
employed on Tuesday and leading up to
the election which is Elevate election
denying Republicans in other words keep
reminding voters they deny the results
they deny the results they deny the
results we have exit polls now which
tell us a lot about whether that was an
effective strategy we're going to talk
about a New York Court's decision to
block Democratic gerrymandering which is
potentially handing the Republican Party
a Lifeline in retaking the house and uh
we've talked about gerrymandering many
times before we will talk about it again
today and lastly
um women's basketball player Brittany
Greiner who was arrested charged and
convicted in Russia
this is so horrible is now being
transferred to a Russian penal colony
according to her attorneys it is
horrifying what is going on we will talk
about it and we will talk about much
more how do you get access to the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad it's
super easy you go to joinpakman.com that
is all there is to it you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now and I look
forward to seeing many of you on today's
bonus show if not we'll be back tomorrow
with a brand new show